pour la première fois les scientifiques
identifient les zones prioritaires à
protéger pour sauver la biodiversité et
cela à l'échelle planétaire c'est le
global
les habitats des espèces rares à
préserver en urgence par exemple ce les
murs n'existe qu'à Madagascar sa
population a chuté de 80% en 20 ans
les habitats riches en biodiversité ce
sont les forêts tropicales 80% des
espèces de la planète y vivent ces
forêts préservent le cycle des pluies le
répacte est mondial
les habitats naturels intacts
les plus grands se retrouvent au Canada
et en Russie c'est là que vivent les
dernières populations de caribou ses
habitats sont essentiels pour la
régulation du climat jusque là épargné
par l'humain mais pour combien de temps
encore